evan is with us in Bowling Green hi Evan
how are you deserve Dave how are you
just the same how can I help
hey I just called in my wife and I
actually are you know I'm just got
understated perspectives and we've gone
through the financial peace class and it
just seems that we waver from it we both
have will make I make twenty eight
thousand she makes about nineteen
thousand year and we both have a say we
both because we're married we have a
$70,000 debt and that's including her
her bachelor's degree from damar College
and then eleven thousand five hundred
and card debt dr. bill six thousand
dollars give or take and then a lower
seventeen hundred dollars and the damar
is the biggest one I think it's around
fifty five fifty five thousand so
together we make forty seven thousand
and I just kind of want to hear your
logic on it my logic on what Oh on what
we should do and how do we get out of it
I felt like that we just just keep
looking at this mountain and it just
never gets any smaller that's because
you don't climb it yeah I mean if you
just sit there and look at it it ain't
gonna get smaller is it laughs yeah I
put one foot up there and start you know
grab ahold and let's go and the only
reason you would start climbing a
mountain though the only reason you
would start working a plan is if you
thought it was going to work there's
something about when you went through
Financial Peace University the switch
didn't flip in your head somehow you
thought as doesn't work are you two gone
and done it I think the only thing that
you I agree with you and that's the hard
part about it is is the application on
an everyday basis and that's it's okay
so we have to keep on track on where
we're going and then it's well the
doctor bill came from where she she was
outside mow the yard without
juice and well we had to go to the ER
she fell in a drainage ditch and cut her
foot a pretty bad net to have stitches
and and it's those things and especially
with our income we don't have we can't
with paying we're trying to do the
snowball playing paid the the smallest
things first and then and then add up
but we it just seems with that and with
certain occurrences throughout life
especially the straightest ditch was
just something that was just unexpected
and it's taking us back and they're just
putting this back into a spot to where
we can't pay extra or we're just paying
the minimums now and finance a car we
bought another car we bought a $1700
lawnmower how did she fall in a ditch
pushing a lawnmower right well a
lawnmower situation was another thing
and we we could have to let the grass
grow or we could have bought a different
man we could have bought a cheaper
lawnmower yeah yeah yeah sorry about
that
that's a moment but I me if you have a
$1700 lawnmower how does she fall in the
ditch well I'm just curious it was a
push she was a push but one out front
and the push mower was well proud of it
that you couldn't ride yes sir oh my god
okay I'll just be curious I'm just now
yeah yeah well you're in success oh you
know what you know here's the thing if
you have a big enough why if you say
let's just say something bizarre okay
something weird okay that's not going to
happen but just to show you an example
okay as a metaphor if if I said that you
were going to die in 14 months if you
did not pay off $25,000 in that in the
next 14 months you'd go nuts yes sir
you'd work like a crazy man yeah you'd
sell stuff and you'd you know you
wouldn't have problems staying on the
budget you would get there because if
you don't you're gonna die you know
that's extreme and that's obviously
weird but I'm
point is you would have a really big
reason that would cause everything to
revolve around that reason and you don't
have a big enough why you're just living
life and you know what what I would say
is this I I want you to get scared of
being normal and you're not scared of
being normal yet enough to cut this crap
out I mean cut your life down to nothing
take six jobs sell so much stuff that
you the kids think they're next I mean
the lawnmower is gone you're pushing the
whole thing you know I'm probably the
car is gone I don't know
everything's gone we're not going on
vacation Christmas is gonna be a craft
it's time to shock the system here talks
you got a detox and you know just clean
out everything that's going on here and
stop putting anything into the system
that's not pure I mean I don't want to
hear about fun I don't want to hear
about anything except sacrifice because
you're gonna die if you don't do this
now again I'm being melodramatic and
crazy but the point is that if that if
that happened you don't care what other
people think you don't care about Friday
you don't care about discomfort
temporarily you will live like no one
else so that later you can live and give
like no one else that's the Y statement
you know do I will I pay the price to
win so I never have to pay a price again
or am I gonna pay the price of
mediocrity and you got that's what it is
you all got to talk about it you got to
go you know we've been doing this stuff
ish an ish Dave ish Financial Peace
University ish gets you ish results and
that's what you've been doing
results ish and I'm not fussing at you
you're just asking me how to do it and
you know when I was a kid no one jogged
there was no one was running in the
neighborhood I grew up in unless
somebody's chasing them okay nobody went
for a run there weren't running shoes
I remember when converse came out with a
basket
of all shoes that were actually cool and
would stop quickly on the gym floor
was the first ones I've ever seen now
everybody wears those throwback converse
and that's what they look like those
humans where you hipsters we're the ones
that how you say when I was a kid but
running shoes running shorts sweats that
matched we had the gray sweatpants that
looked like a balloon that you saw in
the first version of Rocky okay that's
that was it and one day a guy went
running up our street a grown man was
running on our street in those gray
sweatpants and funky-looking little
tennis shoes and the kids we were all
just amazed were like a grown man just
ran up the street we went and told our
parents the next day everybody gathered
on the front porch to watch this grown
man run up the street and it became the
great mystery of the neighborhood that
this grown man was out running and
finally someone got up the courage to
run along beside him and ask him why and
he said well I had a little heart attack
and the doctor said if I didn't lose 60
pounds I was gonna die and so you know
what he did he went for a run he had a
big enough why and he didn't care that
he was the weirdo of the neighborhood
because he was I mean this is a bunch of
rednecks tent around on our front porch
watching this weird guy run up the
street we had never seen anybody do
anything like this but he didn't care
what we thought he wanted to live he had
a big enough why he didn't care what
other people thought he and care about
his temporary discomfort he wanted to
live so he paid a price of ridicule by
others looking on he paid a price of
discomfort and have a greater life
not sure why you gotta have a wine like
that this is the Dave Ramsey show